well bakeries are just as busy as  santa's workshop right now they're  pumping out pie order after pie order  for thanksgiving and getting things  ready for the rest of the season  humboldt suites in henderson has already  maxed out their pie orders for  thanksgiving over the next couple of  days the two bakers will turn out listen  to this nearly  150 pumpkin cream and chocolate cream  pies they're so busy they're hoping to  bring on another team member ahead of  christmas we are going to be doing a lot  of pies and a bunch of cakes and stuff  so and we are sold out for that right  now we're doing a lot more orders now  but when covet hit it it set us back but  now we're coming out of it and things  are great  well local economic experts are  encouraging people to shop local on  black friday more will be offering  online discounts than ever before